you
you
you
hello hello hello guys hello guys and
welcome to GameSpot live if you guys are
just now tuning in this is a presented
up by PlayStation Plus we are gonna be
playing some Call of Duty warzone
tonight which as you guys know is kind
of been like a game of choice as of
lately I've been pretty pretty addicted
at to playing it so that's what we're
gonna play today if you guys also was
not aware PlayStation Plus does come
with a free content hack that includes a
special operator skinned XP token a
double XP token weapon blueprints and
more so we are gonna jump right in to
some what war zone and hopefully we can
get some wins today that's the that is
the goal is getting ones today that is
the goal which was luck wish us luck
first game first W that's the plan
that's the plan alright hello everybody
and shot hello hello we are gaming today
we are absolutely gaming
[Music]
only wins only W's maybe a few few
gulags but we're gonna break out of it
easy peasy
gonna win our 1v1 easy easy
easy
okay okay okay okay are we dropping
where we dropping I'm thinking we go to
our classic train station I'm thinking
that's the spot we drop that snot has
never got a gotten you know food whose
severe I feel like we got a drop train
stray soon
I think it's just right the game knows
the game knows
home
is over we're getting less game easy
easy easy
like do we have been on the the gym
teacher skin from day one he knew you
know
we put drop I feel like we cook quick
bro I feel like we got to do it
you never abandon home
by station is okay alright this is gonna
be some good loot on earth I can feel it
or not okay
there's another there's some nice nice I
definitely heard shots to the right of
things
yeah they're still shots the left over
here bedrooms
I don't know how that is sounds decently
close I think it's by the gas station it
sounds like we might be okay to loot
like a little bit more yeah
same you guys look like all up in trees
I wish they would give credit for down
kills yeah so they are changing that
soon which is I think sorry you came are
you sure if I definitely down that guy
are you sure yeah
definitely then I'm trying to think of
what other places I think maybe that's I
mean South was definitely where those
shots were coming from so I don't know
do we gonna push over there
I don't have any extra armor yet we
don't have much cash either tube I don't
know if that person got shot I revived
not he definitely died I wasn't I looked
like a sniper listen there definitely
shots to her left
sounds look behind us so
an extra armor plate would be real nice
that sounds like pretty close behind us
that excuse only close behind us and
then one at boneyard - we need armor and
we need money we equip the PlayStation
Plus exclusive operator me and do we are
looking fly right now a little bit more
money there summon bone and all of those
were looted
that's where I landed to the right yeah
maybe just have extra and then something
definitely needs them
I like translation doesn't like theirs
to like purchase nations normally pretty
close by
we are in the safe zone
wait that's coming to us I think we
should probably maybe try pushing before
getting more money in general I guess a
death trap
yeah I mean I guess it's the good name
for it no we don't we just need money
though so we got to push somewhere to
loot we could push like you're super
super right there oh this is to buy
stations right next to each other let's
do that maybe
grow fruit oh yeah so you can download
just war zone it is free to play it just
takes a download and you can pick up the
controller and drop right in it was
really nice but obviously with the full
game you do need PlayStation Plus if you
want the entire package play online the
full game okay hopefully these buildings
aren't Luden's we get some money and
then buy a loadout that would be nice
yes that is true that is true guys it's
really nice because if you are using
weapons in this game that you've never
really used in does cross over so XP
crosses over which is really nice for
someone who doesn't normally snipe but I
do snipe in this game so it is nice to
see that the XP crosses over to
multiplayer as well this should
hopefully give us money this contract
alright I'm gonna push this building
hopefully knock it shot going for this
contract
as a big building oh that's that is a
couch that is a couch I'll write plate
here if you guys don't have a listen we
don't talk about the air strike match
that we had we don't talk about it
chat air strikes absolutely hurt in case
you guys didn't know and they will kill
you even through a closed door that
opens my primo I've full five yeah air
strikes absolutely do hurt would not
recommend well that's close that's
really close you only got that several
recent Ivan
grab the knee uh yeah I have lunch
though stuff you can grab up I'm pretty
sure I saw scope for a second I really
want to buy the sniper but I also know I
need to buy ghosts from a loadout all
right what's the worst I can happen
[Music]
hopefully hmm I mean I couldn't buy
another load out if we wanted to buy
snipers I mean that's kind of close
there's a guy on the street right now
further down that canceled
mmm he was kind of going towards the way
the game no we probably shouldn't stick
around
that sounds Joss where we came from yeah
that's like okay well they're just
saying we should go push that just
kidding loser body on my head
[Applause]
yeah sure maybe try pushing towards me
so we can watch these guys
like those chests are so loud I love it
[Music]
yeah probably
[Applause]
right now hearing airstrikes
it's not gonna lie having my hopes and
dreams crushed yesterday by an airstrike
do we want to go to a vice station them
now there's one superstore OSI that
vendor I feel like we should go to the
buy station though cuz UAV would be
super clutch
so how do bounties working are these
worth like it gives a really wide circle
on the map that's highlighted yellow and
if you survive it you get the money
right now to the top of the building
yeah go
they're outside I just went around the
front car I guess you want over to the
other building other building other
building they're moving towards the
green building right now we just have to
watch our backs now I know you guys all
have your grass mats
oh this is this is a far far circle to
be like locked in there's a B TV up here
the guy was like are you use it on holy
cow at the front of the heart
is incredibly hard to see through that
all right break out of the Google you
got this oh there's a team of our left
Cinderella
stopping stopping oh lordy oh gosh I was
fam you should probably heels weekend oh
yeah he's in there he's in here but you
jumped past it like this died I was like
I only see white alright please don't
give me a bad pistol that's all I ask
Oh easy easy easy easy
I'm coming he's your left your left back
this one left side you have to be the
shotgun warrior that is not good to be
son
[Applause]
he's always first yeah you sorta like no
pressure but we don't we did not win our
1v1 we hate to see it I wonder if a team
that the landed on the roof was the same
ones following us probably not alright
oh yeah it says I have zero kills but I
definitely killed somebody oh are you
sure enough being already mmm
you guys saw that right eye down that
first guy in train station house indid I
don't know oh my gosh alright Chad I'm
gonna run the ad break real quick so you
guys can find out more about PlayStation
Plus and then we're gonna get it in
right into the next game today's stream
is sponsored by PlayStation Plus
PlayStation Plus is the gaming
subscription for ps4 which allows access
to online multiplayer as well as two
free ps4 games every month
you also get exclusive digital game
discounts content and more if you're
jumping into Call of Duty warzone you'll
have access to the warzone combat pack
with your PS Plus membership that
includes an operator skin weapon
blueprint double XP token and more don't
forget war zone is a free-to-play
cross-platform experience which means
you can only get the combat pack right
here on ps4 so pick up your controller
download the game and drop into the
action that's what we're doing today
thanks to PlayStation Plus
alright alright alright again guys as
you know this is sponsored by
PlayStation Plus you guys get a free
free exclusive skin if you are playing
on PlayStation Plus this is the skin I'm
currently equipped and playing with you
also get a free blueprint a watch and
other fun things as well you guys don't
need the full game of call duty to play
warzone but of course if you'd like to
play online Call of Duty you do need
PlayStation Plus you're gonna jump in
the next game this is a game I feel it I
feel it you got you gotta send the good
energy out there that you know you're
gonna win that's that's how it's gotta
be done well this is the this is the W
alright we're gonna pay attention to the
gas because that's always super
important and I feel like that's our
weakness as we're always running into
the circle at like the last second oh
she's gotta pay attention to that get
get good loadout get money it was any of
our best
yeah I had I completely forgot as we
usually do yeah this is a W this is a W
I said you got it you got to warm up how
to warm up
what's that put on hit and that
shoulding - I was like this not good he
thought you don't and ran past
yeah all games are warm-up games until
you win John how it works gamer gamer
facts
yes
no but middle of the circle is you think
pretty pretty busy
although you just dropped like a cider
rock once you cut it again
these outside building these are these
are it till there's nothing to need that
month so I came prepared
it's not either of you guys right
money I don't know if anyone landed I
definitely don't hear anybody so
no nowhere I haven't heard anybody he's
definitely not alone
I think there's a crate on that roof can
you jump No
Oh No there definitely isn't free on
these okay I can buy you back but it's
gonna cost you
I expect at least five kills if we bring
it back do I hear stop running
ooh the warden you could maybe bought by
in the harbor Bakula
oh yeah right there okay that was a
perfect spot for him to just drop down I
dropped a scar back back over there kind
of where you are up there he just hit
him once at the blue roof yeah they're
still there sooner they move at the last
second can't tell if there's still the
other team over there it sounds like it
wish I had a butters
maybe we should have don't you think
there's maybe oh yeah
I just don't know if they killed that
other team I was fighting them
I don't know if I like to it to inside
the blue building come again I wouldn't
peek that unless you have a sniper we're
doing cute is he gonna peek again that's
the question
come on that was his head I mean maybe
that's smart
you guys want to push over
I don't know cuz they're probably gonna
be camped in the Attic if you want
[Music]
oh yeah he's coming up iead this is not
good
guy over there over there over there you
just walked right in front of me right
next to that building
I want to go mark it I'm on top of the
roof I should be safe unless they push
it up you jump down Stephon coming from
I'm mark
I'd push it if you can he's running away
he's running towards train station
contact he is running not because the
other one he's there I'm going yeah I
don't know if I should chase that cuz I
don't know if his other teammates are
behind him down and that's decent what
goes in train station definitely seems
like this is the sniper you you'll want
to hit them head shots for sure
sorry just a little pushing right there
on the roof yeah the roof is the worst
case though
Hank I just will read off
so that wasn't a team white because that
guy ran
we should meet I like I kind of want to
push these guys in train station I mean
yeah we know where they are so or to a
federal degree I could on the roof
definitely not good I guess careful I
wouldn't run I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna
guess they're on the roof they're smart
they're on the roof it takes I think a
decent that Oh how's it update yeah
staircases oh my gosh work out great
oh you guys got money English by Luke
maybe elsewhere they're heading on the
route other other other so that
definitely hurts don't recommend getting
sniped I'll give him credit because I
broke his armor and he's still he's
alright there's another guy another guy
sniping mouth so one cyber-shot left
okay he fell off then we should be
careful downstairs
yes we should y-yeah but I also think we
need a loadout Oh should I go buy one
and then bring it back up I'll bite
maybe you have to buy UAV then I don't
have enough let me drop money we are
being yeah do you have any um there's a
gas mouse over here Stefan you have any
extra armor they're gonna be like right
on it yep they're in the gas station do
you think
I'm gonna go into green if you think
they're not gonna instantly rush you
yeah well there ain't there they're
right across the street there so just be
prepared oh my gosh
oh that's unfortunate I not just first
match the second a broke the armor the
third I mean that's smart that one
pushed up I guess all right we're gonna
win these we're gonna win these we're
not we're not going out not like that
beautiful blooded yeah I was like I'm
pretty sure I knew where he was sitting
so I was kind of guessed if he was proud
all right listen if I can get either a
good pistol or even better yet let me be
a shotgun warrior mid he's going to your
left your right on right behind him he's
running that way
Brendan Eich corner he's pushing pushing
you know in the middle you're right
pushing oh my gosh
did you punch him no not good they
really are I just need to like run
around you got this though
you got this yes you do
push the same spot
I think the my issue issue with this
vlog is like I'll get stunned even if I
hit the one of those stunts
really
although I will say the worst way to die
in the gulag is definitely being lit on
fire
that is the most humiliating I guess
getting punched to death all right
you're gonna you're gonna buy us back
listen you're gonna get money you're
gonna buy his back and then we're gonna
clean up get get art get our loadouts
get some money just pop off this is not
out until it's over small circles
[Music]
no pressure yeah you could honestly drop
it grab the cartoon media go so go there
go in 13 oh there's a car pushing you
boy did they see you oh my gosh I don't
think I saw you you need money
oh there's their clothes your left
shoot them out of the car sir does mama
lighten up the car that's your chance
third party it up
got a little the metal call of duty
music really just so you know - there
were definitely people they're coming
right for me take their getaway vehicle
I'll die Oh God oh gosh
you are a wild job by Armour I mean I
know what I'm saying goodbye or enough
there's a shot there's a shot behind you
I don't think they see you until you can
say what for like eight themes so close
dude I I feel like we have that fight
against the people in the gas station
should I have it we should have had it
all right
but it's fine you can go again and then
everything will be okay
everything will be okay guys in case you
guys didn't know this stream is
sponsored by PlayStation Plus which is
an awesome awesome thing because you can
get a combat pack for free if you have
PlayStation Plus which gives you a
really cool operator as well as two free
games every single month exclusive deals
and more if you guys are interested in
learning about placing today's stream is
sponsored by PlayStation Plus
PlayStation Plus is the gaming
subscription for ps4 which allows access
to online multiplayer as well as two
free ps4 games every month
you also get exclusive digital game
discounts content and more if you're
jumping into Call of Duty warzone you'll
have access to the warzone Kombat pack
with your PS Plus membership that
includes an operator skin weapon
blueprint double XP token and more
don't forget warzone is a free-to-play
cross-platform experience which means
you can only get the combat pack right
here on ps4 so pick up your controller
download the game and drop into the
action that's what we're doing today
thanks to PlayStation Plus
alright alright alright so again guys it
wears on is free to place you can
download it pick up your controller and
jump right in
maybe maybe catch me in a game maybe I
get to kill you maybe you kill me I'm
just saying you never know you never
know until you download and try it out
it is for you to play guys like I said
cross-platform as well you don't need a
PlayStation Plus subscription to play
war zone but if you'd like to play the
full game which your XP from warzone
does carry over to the full game you do
need a PlayStation Plus to play online
for the full game let's get in to
another one listen third time's the
charm
this is that or a smart pushes we're
gonna get UAVs we're gonna get bounties
get money that's up the model right
there yeah there you go
if that XP get that XP stream snape
I just I just want a good sniper a good
AR that's what I want at least a good
sniper I'll take I'll take like an mp7 I
just I need a good sniper good snipers
are like ki I wouldn't be mad at a
thermal scope you either because
everyone's go p--'s are so great in this
game till the very last second
I look on the ice like the guy moving
down them in the head my guy was like
well I'm gonna push up and will you get
the rez smart tell you game tell you
Gabe now they have a high ground it's
over I have the high ground
[Music]
all right let's guy this guy there's no
way he's gonna hit the sniper shot not a
moly
new airport
Sorge down
[Music]
for sure scares me advice
yes close a whole lot of people's state
to the safe zone
perf we never landed
yep
there's definitely definitely the game
hasn't pushed out he's behind the Jeep I
have low ammo he's kind of weak I'm just
need the bike killers go and get more
ammo where did this guy run to chat
where's the guy that I doubt oh my god
other guy over here he's on the roof oh
no he's on the roof right above you he's
pushing towards me the roof the roof is
the spot
pump it up like pump up I need a pump up
speech okay
[Applause]
they were checking out honey
[Applause]
listen I usually run shotgun battles you
got to become one with the shotgun
there's a I station both stuff I'm gonna
buy the - we don't have oh you're really
close you know a little bit of cash a
little money we're talking about that's
the money we're talking about okay Ana
de que no matter to me
there's all right don't get shot while
spawning in like
that ruse is about as the world
and is a team on the like secure point
[Music]
listen don't ever underestimate chat the
LMG because you might lose really slow
but it can shred it can definitely shred
although the reload also takes river so
bandages yeah looting the stuff oh
there's no second floor I think there
might stories are on it honestly really
clutch - got a pushing off the Stefan
stop there's two of them two of them
running with a left over
haha I literally came out
on top of this roof I really would love
to get on that roof but I think they
still on top of that roof Oh doc is tons
are my downfall stuns are my downfall a
thousand percent you get stunned it's
just like I'm just gonna stand here that
went downhill from the start from the
start okay
I was not a good start not a good start
stuns this is why you need a class as
fast as you can because if you can like
get the right perks going all you need
the right perks is all you need
all right this is it
ruff ooh you know if they say fourth
time's the charm right after saying
saying
mmm-hmm because this one I have al
hardan his way better
cold-blooded ghosts battle-hardened
those are the perks those are truly the
perks and then you just swap one of your
secondary guns for a better gun and
that's that's all you need I guarantee
chat those are those are the perks
really good everyone's there
you're the one who's like oh wow I'm
taking you with me
alright listen I'm not saying storage
talent is bad but I'm saying look if you
find a good spot
that's although else gas is causing in
your position suggest you get moving
oh yeah there's definitely definitely a
team on one foot oh no weapons in there
then that's good that's good so just be
careful of the roof if they go up top
though you're good you're good to go I
[Music]
am more than satisfied with this
I'm gonna try to go near the top even
though I definitely don't have read of
sue so I feel like there's probably
better parts to use this isn't that
isn't that work cold-blood it is you
mark it off I'm gonna shoot that with my
okay well here's I'm gonna push up on
one of the Tim coming behind them so was
there too
here's somebody below me
I don't know that's so weird cuz it
definitely says stuff and got those
kills but I definitely down front of
them I if you put the last bullet in I
don't know most damage yeah it could be
that couldn't be that makes that would
make more Sun we have enough preload out
you want to do that blow it out over UAV
there's a scar up here if anybody wants
that I like the m13 sometimes a bit
better than the scar should I drop it
here let me see you think much as a UAV
it's four thousand four thousand so
we're close but not there I guess yeah
drop it
there we go now I can you maybe now the
we s yeah light you have you any armored
stuff
try papi ladies only close interesting
this definitely is either either on the
roof
tracks on the ground they're pushing you
you want over this I didn't know UAB is
out of fuel
returning to resupply once on the roof
inside yeah now there are 30 meters away
towards southeast who a leave for an
station
he's right here we might see him he's on
the roof
he's going away because just getting
stairs don't get son
that's the flim I don't see them anymore
oh wait no I see one now yeah there you
guys are just clumping your way up the
stairs I'm trying to be silent
all the way over there here sniper I
don't know okay pretty good I couldn't
use one the close one
[Applause]
that's important for my back if you stay
up there cross back over to the right
and get higher
oh he's still he's still there he's
still on that red mark on that same
truck yeah he's looking at me he's
worried about me right now
Oh as he just crossed this way down side
of an LMG we should chase this guy he's
by himself what's that noise shots were
right the guy that went yeah there was
three people I don't need you actually
kill
another one and they were fighting now
that was a different team
there's pika
here's a loadout I know close the circle
is moving in the mean yeah I guess by
station yeah take high ground again cuz
that sounds kind of close I think we
should try to take high ground the car
coming towards us
they got out they got out I mean they're
out sign up for long until they rush
there's honestly I would just start
popping it as soon as you get close to
it oh I see him he just went in this
building I'm going straight above where
it is there's oh my god there's a whole
other team so there's a guy in that
building yeah he ran into that building
like I don't want to get I don't want
these guys to get on the roof next to us
to the south he hasn't left
Oh there's a guy litter
down there they're looking right at me
[Music]
there's a
we're looking at you Marguerite I'm that
guy on the blue he's in the he's in the
gas right now
let's just go through like you know
boneyard
we got the left teams of the right team
still up though yeah we need who need to
buy maybe a UAV with their money second
if we can fortunate that we didn't get
the loot literally stomping grounds I
need a gas mask too
this is the Luton
yeah you got the proof
for such a bad spot right now it's money
she's like the name of the game we could
sit at the edge of the circle right here
see if anyone comes behind us and
scrapyard I mean there's a bounty over
there we could try to go kill them we
know where he is you guys are gonna get
in the smoke so just just wait
we want to push the bounty that's that's
probably the bounty we could make me
push the buy station and get a UAV and
then oh yeah watch him he's still
Bonnie's gonna disappear in 60 seconds
so oh that's a cluster
no you have to be it like an angle yeah
so it's not good
[Music]
I have no armor actually
he's throwing more nades I think he's
pushing I hear footsteps he's weak he's
really weak outside up front I think I
would've had that he was pushing over
here on the bloom on the blue like this
corner something first gets up and first
gets up and first he's gonna bleed out
get rid of the dead waiting so it's out
did you make it just in time okay so
never mind I think I would have had that
first guy if
I know are you thank you thing was a
whole another team so so Colette would
have picked up and ran all right that
was an unfortunate game for me I
literally had no arm or didn't do much
that game did not do much that game
unfortunately but that's how it goes
sometimes you know sometimes you get
lucky sometimes you get when just end up
with only doing a little bit of damage
and having your team in your backpack
all right you're in there you're ther
backpack I should say but thank you guys
for watching once again this stream was
sponsored by PlayStation Plus if you
guys want to pick up warzone it is a
free-to-play cross-platform all you got
to do is download it and jump in but if
you would like to play the full Call of
Duty game you do need PlayStation Plus
to play multiplayer on line and you get
a really cool combat pack with a
PlayStation Plus which includes the
operator we're using now XP tokens
weapon blueprints and more so definitely
check it out if you guys are interested
in PlayStation Plus your they Street has
gone to that place h+ playstation plus
is the gaming subscription for ps4 which
allows access to online multiplayer as
well as two free ps4 games every month
you also get exclusive digital game
discounts content and more if you're
jumping into Call of Duty warzone you'll
have access to the warzone combat pack
with your PS Plus membership that
includes an operator skin weapon
blueprint double XP token and more don't
forget warzone is a free-to-play
cross-platform experience which means
you can only get the combat pack right
here on ps4 so pick up your controller
download the game and drop into the
action that's what we're doing today
thanks to PlayStation Plus and that
includes today's stream guys thank you
so so much for watching and hanging out
my name is Lisa flora and I stream on
Twitch so I hope to see you guys in war
zone playing and have an awesome rest of
your day stay cool
you
you